amber rose makes her tv hosting debut
i am so excited to have my own show
[Applause]
[Music]
i keep it real on this show and i love
talking about sex amber has no filter
during the premiere of her new vh1
series offering sex and relationship
advice and jokes about celebs here's her
hilarious suggestion for an audience
member who was reluctant to date a man
with a small penis i think you should
cut him off your personal preference is
to have a guy with a bigger
and if it's just not theirs it's not
there go big or go home yes
exactly the 32-year-old model even
mentioned her ex kanye west while
talking about taylor swift and tom
hiddleston's romantic july 4th weekend
her boy tom hiddleston brought the i
heart ts tank top
can i please come next year to your
party
please and taylor as long as you know
that my plus one won't be kanye then
we'll be straight
the show airs every friday at 11 pm on
vh1 we can only imagine how she'll shake
up late night tv next
[Music]